hagamos un poco de práctica y ojalá
también un poco de intuición sobre cómo
sumar y restar vectores de dos
dimensiones así que digamos que por aquí
me tomo al vector a este va a ser mi
vector am que bueno no sé digamos que su
componente x se me ocurre que tome el
valor de 3 y su componente y tome el
valor de menos uno menos uno está bien
ok y también me voy a tomar el vector de
lo voy a poner por aquí tengo también a
este vector b y voy a pensar que este
vector b tiene como componentes no sé
voy a decir que su componente x es 2 y
que su componente james se me ocurre que
sea 3 así que lo tengo por aquí bien
aquí tengo el vector am y aquí tengo el
vector b y qué pasa si yo pienso en el
vector resultante que me queda de sumar
a más
déjame escribirlo el vector resultante
de sumar este vector am
este vector ve y te invito a que pausas
el vídeo y pienses en cuál podría ser
este resultado bueno pues la convención
es la siguiente el vector resultante de
la suma de estos dos va a tener como
componentes y si estamos hablando de la
suma de vectores entonces podemos
simplemente sumar las componentes equis
y así obtendremos la nueva componente x
del vector resultante y sumar las dos
componentes y en sus respectivas
componentes siempre y así obtener la
nueva componente web del vector
resultante entonces la componente x de
este vector resultante va a ser la suma
de 3
este de aquí más dos y bueno la
componente ya va a ser la suma de menos
uno menos uno más
y ya sabemos cuánto es esto por lo tanto
nuestro vector resultante va a tener
como componente x 32 lo cual sabemos que
es 5 y como componente y menos 13 lo
cual es 2
aquí tenemos sus componentes bien pues
esto fue bastante sencillo entonces qué
te parece si en lugar de sumar pensamos
en cómo restar dos vectores qué pasaría
si le restamos cuál sería el resultado
de tomarme al vector am y restarle y
restarle el vector b cuál va a ser este
resultado y bueno seguramente tú puedes
adivinar o al menos imaginarte qué
pasaría si restas el vector b en lugar
de sumar al vector b
y bueno cómo pudiste imaginarte en lugar
de sumar las componentes
correspondientes lo que vamos a hacer es
restar las entonces nuestra componente x
será la componente x del vector am - la
componente x del vector b y por lo tanto
le quedaría de la siguiente manera como
3 que es la componente x el vector am -
a esto lo voy a quitar la componente x
del vector b y después nuestra
componente james va a ser la componente
i del vector am - la componente i del
vector b y entonces me va a quedar lo
siguiente me va a quedar menos 1 - 1 - 3
- 3 y ahí están mis dos componentes
entonces el vector resultante sería el
vector que tiene como componente x 13
menos 12 es 1 y como componente y menos
4 - 1 - 3 es menos 4
lo que acabo de mostrarte es la
convención para sumar y restar vectores
de dos dimensiones como los sectores a y
b ahora pensemos un poco en cómo podemos
representar de una manera visual lo que
está sucediendo
primero pensemos en cómo representar
visualmente la suma del vector a con el
vector b y para eso voy a trazar por
aquí un par de ejes este va a ser mi eje
y por aquí me voy a tomar a mi eje
más o menos se van a ver así deja de
poner que este es mi eje james este es
mi eje x el valor más grande que tengo
en james es 3 creo que sí que ve muy
bien aquí y el valor más bajo que tengo
en que es menos 4 también cabe aquí y
bueno en x el valor más grande que tengo
es 5 y el menor es 1 así que está
perfecto por aquí bien empecemos nuestro
vector tiene como coordenadas 3 - 1 así
que déjame ponerlo 3 x 1 2
y menos uno menos uno voy a ponerlo en
su forma estándar entonces su punto
inicial está en el origen y su punto
final va a estar en el punto 3 -1 es
decir va a estar aquí este va a ser
nuestro vector y este va a ser nuestro
vector a dell
también podemos poner su punto final
donde sea
podríamos cambiarlo de sitio mientras
tenga la misma magnitud y dirección
podemos moverlo entonces este de aquí es
nuestro vector
am y qué pasaría con nuestro vector de
bueno nuestro vector b tiene como
componentes 23 entonces éste podría
tener su punto de inicio en el origen y
se vería más o menos así 2 en x y 12 3
en 10 y entonces se vería de esta forma
su punto inicial estaría en el origen y
bueno su punto al final estaría en el 23
justo por aquí y entonces lo podemos ver
de esta manera aquí tendríamos a nuestro
vector b pero si lo que queremos hacer
es sumar el vector a con el vector b
no voy a poner al vector b en su forma
estándar es decir que empieza en el
origen lo que voy a hacer es mover al
vector ver de tal manera que su punto
inicial queden en el punto final del
vector
o dicho otra manera
la cola del vector ve con la cabeza del
vector
y entonces cómo se vería bueno pues si
yo tengo aquí al vector am y quiero
poner justo aquí el punto inicial del
vector b entonces el vector bm está
diciendo que hay que caminar dos
unidades hacia la derecha y tres hacia
arriba entonces habrá que caminar 12 y
entonces el vector bs va a ver de la
siguiente manera vamos a caminar 2 la
derecha y 3 hacia arriba y su punto
final va a estar justo aquí y entonces
así se va a ver mi vector b se va a ver
algo más o menos así y bueno observa que
este vector b es exactamente igual que
el vector b que dibuje en un inicio cuyo
punto final estaba justo por aquí y se
veía más o menos algo así recuerdas es
el mismo vector b solamente que lo
desplace pero tiene la misma magnitud y
la misma dirección y entonces ahora
puedo imaginarme cuál es el vector
resultante de a más bien va a ser el
vector que tenga como punto inicial
y como punto final el punto final del
segundo vector es decir del vector b el
vector resultante de la suma de estos
dos se va a ver de la siguiente manera
se va a ver justo así va a ser este
vector que tengo aquí y ahora observa
para llegar al punto final de este
vector necesitamos caminar 1 2 3 4 5
unidades hacia la derecha y 12 unidades
hacia arriba para llegar justo aquí es
por eso que este vector tiene como
componentes 5 2
este es el vector resultante de la suma
del vector am con el vector b ahora
pensemos qué va a pasar cuando me tomo
la resta de estos vectores bueno pues lo
primero que vamos a hacer es mantener el
vector aquí y ahora en lugar de poner el
punto inicial del vector b justo en el
punto final del vector am lo que voy a
poner es el punto inicial pero del
vector menos b 10 vector - b o b
negativo tendrá la misma magnitud que el
vector b pero dirección contraria
entonces en lugar de ir 12 unidades a la
derecha y 123 unidades hacia arriba voy
a ir en dirección contraria es decir 12
unidades a la izquierda por aquí y bueno
voy a bajar 3 unidades 1 2 3 por aquí y
entonces saber más o menos por acá mi
punto final de este vector menos b es
decir que mi vector menos b se va a ver
más o menos así este de aquí sería mi
vector menos b dicho de otra manera
estoy sumando al vector am el vector
menos ven esto es exactamente lo mismo
que tomarme al vector am y restarle el
vector b
entonces mi vector resultante del vector
a menos el vector b va a ser el vector
dejando cambiar de color
va a ser el vector que tiene como punto
inicial el origen y como punto final el
punto final del vector menos b y
entonces se va a ver más o menos así
este va a ser mi vector final mi vector
resultante y observamos que caminamos 1
a la derecha
y si bajamos 1 2 3 4 el día y es por eso
que llegamos a este evento resultante es
más déjame poner con otro color
el otro vector para que se distinga más
fácilmente este otro vector lo voy a
poner con este color y mejor voy a
cambiar un poco la anotación para
ponerlo con este color y lo visualiza es
mejor en fin espero que todo esto tenga
un poco de sentido para ti y si
solamente te dan los componentes lo que
quería decirte es que si sumas los
vectores debes de sumar las
correspondientes componentes y si estás
restando vectores entonces bueno espera
se está restando el vector veb del
vector
vas a restar las correspondientes
componentes de las correspondientes
componentes de a y eso es todo por este
vídeo